Hello the internet, I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're the Slow Mo Guys
and today we're in 'Bama.
Roll tide.
Indeed.
We don't really do gun videos very often
on this challenge, do we?
Yeah, tend not to.
Last time we were here,
and we had an M4 on fully automatic.
Very scary.
Yeah.
We've also been known to use
a dweeby little air pistol,
but today we're massively
stepping it up a notch.
By approximately one notch.
I can't even fit in the frame with it.
Yeah, see you later.
Destin from SmarterEveryFay has lent us
this beefcake of a 50 cal.
Thanks Destin.
Once again.
It's gonna blow you away.
You want me to fire it?
Oh, you're gonna be firing it, yeah, yeah.
Absolutely, yeah.
Oh no.
The other one I was terrified of.
This one's gonna stop my heart.
It's gonna detach my brain-stem.
Ridiculous.
Can I try holding it?
Yeah, here you go.
All right.
Are you all right there, breath.
This is not messing around.
If it looks heavy, that's because it is.
I'm trying to compare it
to something weight wise.
It's like a TV.
It is.
It's like a very big tele.
A deadly TV that could destroy like cars.
All right, you take it back,
'cause I'm terrified.
All right.
All right so let's start
setting up Phantoms,
and getting some lovely high speed shots.
Yeah.
It's bigger than I thought it would be.
Is it, it's very big.
It's large.
It is.
Yeah.
Why'd you have this?
Why?
Yeah.
To hang out with you guys .
That's pretty much it.
If you buy a 50 cal we'll
come over and see you Destin.
That's pretty much how that happened.
Thanks for having us, Destin.
Why am I going first?
Look at the size of the round.
Look at it, I'd be proud of that I think.
Look at the size of the magazine as well.
This is like twice the
size of a normal magazine.
I've only seen them on the floor
in like Call of Duty and Battlefield.
Yeah, it's huge.
And they disappear.
Look at the size of it next to his nose.
That's it, now up.
That's it, so now all you
need to do is make ready
by pulling the cocking
handle back and releasing,
then it's made ready to fire.
All right.
Gonna fire!
Oh, yes.
The barrel comes miles back.
I tried to open my eye.
Oh yeah?
Yeah.
And?
And, well it closed for sure.
It's so incredibly violent.
It's meaty isn't it.
You look so profess.
I look profess?
You look like an operator.
Oh, okay.
You opened both your eyes.
Look at your serious face.
Here we go, here we go.
The thing is, you closed
your eyes because you knew
you were gonna pull the trigger.
Look, you closed your eyes,
and then pulled it.
My mindset was,
I'm gonna open my eyes
and pull the trigger.
And then I closed them.
It was so funny.
Oh God.
My face.
Goodness me.
I love that it, like the
air moved before the gun,
and it like shook your face,
and then the gun shakes you afterwards.
There's an incredible amount of force.
That's not too bad.
It's quite fun.
I'll tell ya, that is tooth shattering.
Yeah.
You can see the shockwave visibly go
from the end of the weapon there,
just follows it all the
way down the gun into me,
and then I react like a sack
of meat and bone.
It's like a
very violent Newton's Cradle.
Yeah.
Lovely stuff.
Hench.
All right, so we got some
nice high speed shots there.
Yeah, lovely.
Of the actual gun going off.
What should we shoot with it?
I wanna see how much water we can kick up.
Luckily, there's a pond right there.
How high do you think
the water splash will go?
I reckon 30 feet.
30 feet?
Yeah, quite high.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm gonna shoot it really wide
then, leaving a lot of room
in the upper frame for the splash zone.
Okay.
Okay, firing!
Firing!
Ah yes.
There's like multiple
impacts on the surface.
Did some extra gubs come out with it?
Look at that one tiny bit
just going straight up.
That splash of water
is not messing around.
That's ridiculous.
Does it come out of frame?
You panned up.
I panned up with it.
Yes.
I was like, woop.
Nice, you got it all.
Yeah, it's the same color as
the sky, but it went beyond
the top of the treeline.
From here, wow.
Well how many feet is that?
I don't know.
So it went equal to the height
of that part of the tree.
That is about,
about 25 meters up.
Which I think is like a mile and a half.
Yeah, something like that.
I have to say though, I don't
think I've felt more badass
than I did then.
You caught a dragonfly!
You scared a dragonfly, is what you did.
All right.
The dragonfly is like,
someone just shot my pond with a 50 cal.
I was trying to get it on,
lay some eggs down there.
I got a fish.
The dragonfly just flying away.
That was wicked.
All right, that's a very easy target,
so why don't we see if
you can hone in your aim,
and we'll revisit our
candle shooting video.
How 'bout that?
Oh.
You got it?
Yeah.
Go ahead, rack it and fire.
'Kay, safety off.
You missed!
No.
You missed.
No, that's bang on.
Dan, analyzed the footage.
Yeah.
You got it so close that
the wind put out the candle,
and then it re-lit itself.
No.
Yeah.
You are having to curve
a bullet around the Earth
to hit this candle.
Yes, the distances involved.
Yeah, yeah.
All right, we're gonna shoot
ground level with some debris
on the floor.
It's just leaves, we'll
see if it kicks 'em up.
Ready?
Yep!
Yeah, it's a good visualization
of how far that spreads.
It just looks like it comes out,
'cause the baffle here, the huge baffle,
it's like an artillery baffle.
That's baffling.
Like forces it all the way
back around here.
Look at the way it twists it.
You see how the air comes
out, it's like circular.
It's a vortex.
It's amazing.
It's like an instant wind storm.
Yeah.
They went flying.
Now looking at that, I can't imagine
what that's like for bugs walking around.
Imagine an ant.
Just one day looking
for food, and the next--
Bloody hell !
He's deaf, and he's 10 feet
from where he was before.
Well Dan, I thought that was
some lovely looking footage.
The shock waves that
come out of that thing.
I'll tell ya, I've got a headache.
You fired it like twice?
Yeah.
I fired it about 15 times.
I actually got a headache
from filming you firing it.
The pressure wave still hit me every time.
It rattles your brain.
It's a brain rattler.
Like even if you know
it's gonna happen, right,
when it gets fired, if you're
not firing it yourself,
you can't help but jump.
You just can't help it.
Yeah, yeah.
I agree.
If you're gonna get into
the stealth industry,
I don't recommend this
as your weapon of choice,
because everyone will look at you.
Its got a sling on it as
well, so you can have a sling.
Just walk along with it.
Hopefully you enjoyed that video.
Feel free to follow us
on Twitter, or Instagram?
Forget Twitter, we'll
do Instagram this week,
how 'bout that.
Same name?
Same name.
This is Destin's gun, and we
used Destin's camera as well,
so why don't you give some
love to Destin's channel,
SmarterEveryDay.
I watch it all the time.
And you can subscribe to
us as well if you want.
Yeah, that's fine.
We will see you right back
here for the next video.
Can I put this down yet?
It's really heavy?
Yeah, let's put it down.
Let's pack it away.
It's doing my back in.
Don't carry that around with you.
Good lord.
You wanna go get some barbecue?
Yeah.
I mean, we are in Alabama.
My back.